staying with our top story now let's
take a closer look at the Sikh activist
Hardeep Singh nijar a 45 year old Najar
left India for Canada in 1997 and became
a prominent Sikh leader in the province
of British Columbia he publicly
campaigned for khalistan the creation of
an independent Sikh Homeland in the
Punjab region of India India describe
ninja as a terrorist who had a militant
separatist group accusations he denied
well just this year Najar was working on
an unofficial worldwide vote by Sikhs on
whether they support separating from
India
Canadian media reported he had received
threats in the past because of his
activism
is the spokesman and legal council of
the world seek organization of Canada he
believes India was involved in niger's
killings
it's been incredibly validating uh we as
Canadian six have for years said that
India is interfering here in Canadian
sick Affairs uh we had identified strong
fears that Mr Niger was the target of an
Indian assassination plot and to have
the Prime Minister get up and say that
today that's uh that's confirming those
uh those concerns and it's like I said
very validating Hardeep Singh Nidra was
the president of one of the largest
secretoras in Canada he was also a very
strong Advocate a vocal advocate for
kalistan which is a sovereign sex State
and we here in Canada enjoy freedom of
expression but India had repeatedly
insisted that Canada's silence uh Mr
ninja as well as those six who are
campaigning for kalistan and India
simply doesn't understand that that's
not legally possible but to go to the
extent of having a targeted killing on
foreign soil This falls into the uh
bizarre I mean this is a terrorist act
by India and I I'm I'm surprised that
they would go this far to be honest what
I am concerned about is India using this
moment in time to create tensions to
once again use its uh tentacles here in
Canada to create uh moments of violence
create conflict and that's not beyond
what they've already been doing so uh
six Hindus Muslims we all live here
peacefully but what India has very
actively tried to do is create conflict
and create the myth of sick extremism in
Canada
is the national spokeswoman for India's
ruling baharatiya janata party joins us
now from New Delhi thank you so much for
joining us do you believe the Canadian
prime minister is wrong when he says
there are credible reasons to suspect
India was involved in the assassination
of Singh nijar
well thank you for having me first of
all I must express my anguish at the
language used by the Canadian Prime
Minister and the foreign Ministry at the
strongest strong words and a lie that is
so blatant and also alive which is
completely unsubstantiated
India in fact has been at the receiving
end of sick extremism
just last month we saw a float in one of
the uh in one of the festivals of of a
former prime minister Indira Gandhi who
was not also part of my party but from a
prime minister's assassination and the
float exhibited the glorification of our
former Prime Minister's assassination to
which the Indian government took a
bridge not just that Not only was the
Indian flag desecrated but there were
threats made against Indian diplomats
time and time again about the latest set
of allegations that have been made and
very serious uh wild allegations let me
read out and reiterate what our ministry
and what Indian standards the ministry
of external Affairs is saying that these
allegations are are not only being
rejected by us where they are completely
absurd
targeted killing in a foreign land
whereas we have been suffering the
interference of Canada and his diplomats
in our matters because the Kurdistan
supporters actually are seeking
secession of India breaking down of
Indian uh territory so we stand for our
sovereignty and our integrity okay but
the fact of the matter is that such a
strong yeah if you let me jump in so
Canadian officials are complaining that
India is not cooperating with the
investigation why not cooperate with the
Canadians if the Indian government has
nothing to hide
well that is the Canadian charge that is
a charge by the community
has spelled it out many times earlier
that this is in fact the worst kind of
host what bank politics that Justin
Trudeau's government is indulging in
the the there was a killing of this
gentleman and it was very well known
that it was a gang war it has nothing to
do with Indian diplomats Indian agencies
and it has nothing to do with Indian uh
government whatsoever yet these serious
charges are being made and at that level
of the Prime Minister I think it's
extremely unfortunate uh Indian
government is completely uh uh you know
cooperating in the investigation and I
really think the Canadian government
should do more in controlling extremism
on their soil and anti-india activities
where Indian diplomats are threatened
there are play cards okay this place
this this place where bounties on their
names are given and when the Indian flag
is desecrated even from the high
commission itself I think it's a very
serious matters sure you've made that
point let me put let me put to you if I
may let me put to you when you when you
speak to
okay when you when you speak to seek
activists though this is what they point
out we've not only had the killing of
Singh Nija
uh in June
we've had the killing of several
prominent Sikh figures and other
minority figures such as paramjit Singh
panjwal shot dead in Pakistan May the
6th he was the chief of the khalistan
Commando Force Man Singh Malik who was
accused by India of involvement in a
1985 bombing shot dead in Surrey in July
2022 the killing of said Khalid Raza a
better Commander shot dead in Karachi
February 27
2023 and the list goes on it hilarious
what do you say to those that's that's
their narrative they say yeah I want to
there's a number of people who are
considered either terrorists or enemies
or threats to India who have been killed
in the last year and a half I heard you
the first time yes so do you attribute
all these killings or deaths to Indian
and Indian agencies I mean isn't it
hilarious whether it's a killing in
Karachi or somewhere else in Pakistan uh
you wanted to blame the Indian
government for the same no this is not
this is not my position
let's be absolutely clear this is the
accusation
25 can I yeah can I just finish what I
was saying what I was saying March 22 25
year old from India was attacked 21 year
old Indian student Karthik vasudeva
attacked shot dead in Toronto a statue
of Mahatma Gandhi at the Vishnu Temple
desecrated
20 and then August 22 in Indian radio
host Jyoti Sigma attacked why because he
was a supporter of the Indian government
and did not agree with the khalistan
Believers and activists so and then
there is a float depicting Indira
Gandhi's assassination
but you're not answering the question
I'll let you finish the thought but
you're really not us answering the
question is your narrative that all of
these killings I mentioned I've got a
list of more of them your response to
those who say they suspect Indian
involvement is that this these are all
coincidences that in the last year and a
half people identified as threats to
India being killed
well you know one charge is as good as
the other
just because their charges are that
these killings which have happened all
over in Canada and in Pakistan
um will now be attributed to uh you know
Indian agencies I think it's just
ridiculous ours is a government which is
never has never had a track record of
anything of this kind
one and most importantly we are
committed to the rule of law so surely
we can't be compared to the State of
Affairs in Pakistan
because ours is a vibrant robust
democracy which is doing rather well so
I don't think that there is any need to
believe the the the extremist element
and and uh bow to them and to acquires
to their allegations and and agree with
them and put the name on India our India
has nothing to do with it all right so
why since you mentioned democracy and
and a track record how would you respond
to a number of civil liberty groups who
say such as the Freedom House report of
2022 that the current Indian government
has developed a history of persecuting
minorities it says quote a rise in
persecution affecting the Muslim
population harassment of journalists
non-governmental organizations and other
governmental critics
The sweden-based v-dem Institute names
India is one of the worst autocratizers
in the last 10 years in its democracy
report of 2023 are those also wrong
well obviously and what is The
credibility of Freedom House this this
agency and this report would have you
believe that India is worse off than
Hong Kong and Afghanistan now would
anybody in the right mind believe it
they had these have been refuted many
times over I live in India and also the
vedem Institute and The Economist
intelligence of Indian Belfast teams no
I think this is just a very hackneyed
sort of a narrative which has been used
far too often and with very little
credibility whatsoever so I think it we
would do we could do better than that
instead of uh you know dragging India
into something that is India is not uh
guilty of to put it and and he Heap all
these in cells on India knowing very
well that none of them are true so just
just pray for them why do you think the
Canadians are going after India
is that this is happening in India does
it make does it actually make it
true
there's a lot of them that I've heard on
your show this time okay I'm sorry to
say that and the Indian government
stronger no you have your right to your
opinion but why do you think the
Canadian government
why do you think then the Canadians are
also saying this credible evidence if
there is no credible evidence to suspect
India they also lacking credibility and
a bunch of uh uncredible ngos as well
well they can produce
[Music]
oh the Canadian government will provide
the evidence linking the killing of this
gentleman with that of Indian government
or any of the Indian agencies or
whatsoever it is totally up to them to
prove this but I think it is totally
unporated it's a blatant lie and it is
rather absurd to say
uh to say at the very least
okay it's very shocking that this
language has been used and the Canadian
Prime Minister should fall victim to
this kind of vote Bank politics and
compulsion of what bank politics in his
own uh country to this extent it is
rather shameful I say all right thank
you so much Shazia early for answering
those questions and sharing your
perspective with us